Đó đá, xuống rận cô họ trong bài thí xác thành một tô hạt a 1.
Sẽ tăng cửa hai 1 lâm lên 1 mì cầu, thời gian là bài tụng mời chiến
tăng lên hai mì hoài phút. Thí xếng người chấm đặt bài thí khi đệ trả lời đồng
và mi sảo chiến 1 mì cầu hỏi. Đối với bài thí lý tuy xế 1 tô hạt 1 mì 1,
xế bà bản và cơ xế mấy hạt 1. Sổ lộn được tăng lên từ 2.
1 lâm lên 5 mì cầu hỏi. Tăng thời gian là bài tụi 2 mì phút lên và mì bà phút.
Đặt khi chả lời đồng bộ mâm chỉ nằm cầu người thí xác thành bằng lại
ổ tô hạt bây, tăng số lộn cô hỏi từ 3 mười lì nằm cầu.
Thời ra là bài tăng từ 2 mì phút lên và mà phút.
Nguyên thí được chấm đặt khi chả lời đồng bộ mâm chỉ nằm cầu.
Các hẳng xế 1 xế bà đây, cùng nhóm dễ phép lại xế kéo một rơ mắc.
Cũng đời đầy xuất tăng số lộn cô hỏi thời ra là bài bà tí lý chả lời đồng.
Chúng đau nhóm hạn xế 1 a, c-a, đe, 1 a, đe, đe, a, đe, a, có số cầu hỏi các nhất bởi chiếm mấy câu tìm trong sống
mì phút. Dự thào cũng bộ xung nhiều dạng cô hỏi mới không chỉ dừng lỗi hình thống chọn đáp hả như
hệ này. Thất dạng cô hỏi gồm gửi chọn đáp hả em đúng sai. Nói đáp hả đồng và sử lý tình
hồn dau thông qua video, lý hả nổi dung cô hỏi sế bộ xung kiến thức về bộ lộ tình sự.
Lên quan đến nhóm tội phạm bizo thông pháp lợt, sử lý vý phạm hành chính trung lý vực trật tự ăn tòa sớt đứng bộ,
nhận thức về phòng người ta nạn sâu thông. Dên tự hạn xế một trở lên để tìm bộ xung nhận thức về vận tài đu bộ.
Theo điều sốt có hỏi sử dụng phần bề máy tinh chào đổi lý tục, nhằm chẳng tình chạm học mèo,
bụt thích xinh vài năm gửi kinh thức pháp lợp bizo tự ăn tòa sớt đứng bộ và các quy định có lý doanh quán.